.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
AT THIS HOUR AS WE CONTINUE,
REPUBLICANS ARE STILL INCHING
TOWARDS A MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE.
MAY END UP BEING DECIDED BY
REPUBLICANS IN THE DEEP BLUE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
MIKE GARCIA REMAINS AHEAD IN
CALIFORNIA'S 27th DISTRICT.
KEVIN KYLIE IS AHEAD IN
CALIFORNIA 3.
YOUNG KIM AND MICHELLE STEELE
ARE CLOSING IN AND KATIE PORTER
IS IN A TIGHT RACE IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
REPUBLICANS NEED 218 SEATS.
AS YOU CAN SEE, WE PUT IT ON THE
SCREEN TO WIN THAT HOUSE
MAJORITY, WHICH IT APPEARS THEY
ARE HEADED TOWARDS.
JOINING US NOW, NEWT GINGRICH.
IT'S PRETTY REMARKABLE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT AT DAM LAXALT
IS ODDS ON FAVORITE IN NEVADA.
WE HAVE A HIGHWAY NOW FOR BLAKE
MASTERS BASED ON NEW NUMBERS.
WE HAVE MORE OUTSTANDING VOTES
TONIGHT.
400,000 OF THE 650 OUTSTANDING
ARE DAY-OF HANDED IN BALLOTS
THAT BLAKE MASTERS HAVE BEEN
WINNING 68% OF THOSE.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING STORY
TONIGHT.
AND THEN THE RUN-OFF IN GEORGIA,
A STATE YOU KNOW WELL.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON ALL OF IT.
NEWT GINGRICH.
>> I THINK THIS IS THE WILDEST
ELECTION OF MY ENTIRE CAREER.
>> Sean: 1994 WAS A BIG NIGHT.
>> IT WAS.
IN 2014 WHEN WE WON, REINCE
PRIEBUS ASKED ME TO DEVELOP A
REVIEW TO FIGURE OUT.
I THINK RONNA McDANIEL, THE
CHAIR OF THE RNC OUGHT TO SET UP
A SIMILAR REVIEW COMMITTEE.
APPARENTLY HOUSE REPUBLICANS GOT
FIVE OR SIX MIDDLE MORE VOTES
THAN DEMOCRATS BUT DIDN'T
TRANSLATE IN TO THE SAME
COMPARABLE NUMBER OF SEATS.
WE NEED TO EXAMINE THAT
APPARENTLY SOME INCUMBENTS LOST
THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE.
NO INCUMBENT LOST IN 2020 WITH
KEVIN McCARTHY'S LEADERSHIP AND
NO REPUBLICAN LOST IN 1994 WHEN
WE TOOK THE HOUSE.
SO A LOT OF THINGS TO ASK
OURSELVES.
I TALKED TO HERSCHEL.
HE'S OUT THERE RUNNING EVERY
GAME THAT WENT TO OVERTIME IN
HIS CAREER, HE WON.
HE SEES IT THE SAME WAY.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO WIN.
I AGREE WITH LINDSEY.
EVERYBODY THAT CAN HELP HIM
OUGHT TO GO TO TEAMHERSCHEL.COM
AND DO SO.
I THINK THAT ADAM IS VERY SMART.
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
NEVADA.
I THINK ADAM WILL WIN.
I THINK NOW THAT BLAKE MASTERS
WILL WIN.
I LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
KARI LAKE.
SHE'S GOING TO WIN.
BY THE TIME THIS IS OVER, EVERY
EFFORT OF THE NEWS MEDIA TO MAKE
REPUBLICANS FEEL BAD WILL FALL
APART.
THE BIGGEST CHANGE IN WASHINGTON
WILL BE WHEN NANCY PELOSI HANDS
THAT GAVEL OVER TO KEVIN
McCARTHY.
YOU GO FROM A RADICAL LIBERAL TO
A SOLID CONSERVATIVE.
THE BIGGEST SINGLE CHANGE.
IN MY SENSE FROM BIDEN'S PRESS
CONFERENCE, HE DIDN'T -- HE HAS
NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING ON.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE DOWN THE SAME
DISASTROUS ROAD.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
MESSAGE -- WHAT ADVICE DO YOU
GIVE HERSCHEL?
IT'S INTERESTING.
HE NEVER LOST AN OVERTIME GAME
IN HIS LIFE.
THAT'S NOT A RECORD MANY PEOPLE
CAN SAY.
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW IF HE
WILL DO IT, BUT I TOLD HIM
SOMETHING THAT I LEARNED MANY,
MANY YEARS AGO FROM A FORMER
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF OHIO.
HE USED TO TAKE HIS WALLET OUT
AND PUT IT IN THE PODIUM.
HE SAID, LET ME TELL YOU WHAT
THIS RACE IS ABOUT.
MY OPPONENT WANTS TO TAKE MONEY
OUT OF YOUR WALLET.
I WANT TO PUT MONEY IN TO YOUR
WALLET.
DO YOU WANT MORE MONEY IN YOUR
WALLET OR DO YOU WANT THEM
TAKING IT OUT OF YOUR WALLET?
THIS GUY WON AN AMAZING NUMBER
OF GOVERNORSHIPS BECAUSE PEOPLE
GOT IT.
THE KEY RACE HERE IS SIMPLE.
YOU HAVE -- WARNOCK SOMEBODY
THAT IS TO THE LEFT OF BERNIE
SANDERS.
I MEAN, WARNOCK IS GENUINELY
RIGHT AT THE EDGE OF EXTREME
SOCIALISM.
HE HAS A TERRIBLE RECORD AS A
LANDLORD WHERE THEY KICKED
PEOPLE OUT OF HOUSES FOR AS
LITTLE AS $26.
A REMARKABLE STORY.
>> Sean: AND HE TALKS ABOUT
CHARACTER.
LOOK AT HIS FRIENDS.
YOU KNOW, LUIS FARRAKHAN AND
JEREMIAH RIGHT AND FIDEL CASTRO.
BY THE WAYED, SPEAKING OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, HE WAS
ACCUSED OF THAT AND ARRESTED FOR
OBSTRUCTING ANNIST VESTGATION
INTO HIS CAMP FOR CHILD ABUSE.
WHY DO YOU THINK REPUBLICANS
WILL GET A -- THEY'RE GOING TO
GET A MAJORITY IT APPEARS.
IT'S NOT ANYWHERE WE THOUGHT IT
WAS.
BUT THEY WON BY MORE THAN 6
MILLION VOTES.
THAT DOESN'T ADD UP TO ME.
>> THAT'S WHY I THINK WE NEED A
SERIOUS COMMITTEE TO STOP AND
TAKE A LOOK.
AS YOU KNOW, EVERY MODEL I
BELIEVE IN FAILED IN THIS
ELECTION.
THAT'S WHY I WAS VERY CONFIDENT
GOING INTO ELECTION DAY.
I SPENT THREE DAYS CAMPAIGNING
WITH KEVIN McCARTHY WATCHING HIM
WORK, SEEING HOW HE WAS DOING
IT.
IT WAS REMARKABLE.
HE'S RAISED $480 MILLION.
THIS IS THE MOST DIVERSE, MOST
INCLUSIVE HOUSE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IN HISTORY.
THEY DEVELOPED A COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA THAT IS MUCH MORE
SOPHISTICATED THAN WHAT WE DID
WITH THE CONTRACT WITH AMERICA
BACK IN 94.
SO I REALLY WENT IN TO ELECTION
NIGHT -- WE WENT TO WATCH
RETURNS WITH KEVIN.
I FELT GOOD THAT 3S SOMETHING
MISSING HERE.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
WHEN I SAW THE COOK REPORT,
WHICH SAID AS OF THIS MORNING
THAT SIX MILLION MORE VOTES FOR
REPUBLICANS I THINK AS
CALIFORNIA COMES IN, IT MAY
SLIDE DOWN TO FIVE MILLION.
WE HAVE FIVE OR SIX MIDDLE MORE
VOTES AND WE DON'T PICK UP A
BUNCH OF SEATS?
WE NEED TO ANALYZE THAT.
SOMETHING GOING ON THAT WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
A LOT OF THE EXPERT ANALYSIS
BASED ON RACES ARE WRONG WHEN
YOU START LOOKING AT THE VOTES.
SO THERE'S A LOT TO BE LEARNED
OUT OF THIS.
KEVIN McCARTHY, I CAN'T WAIT FOR
THE MOMENT WHERE PELOSI HAS TO
HAND, IF SHE'S STILL THERE,
KEVIN McCARTHY THE GAVEL AND THE
DEGREE TO WHICH -- IN COMMITTEES
AND INVESTIGATIONS AND
SCHEDULING THINGS ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU'RE IN A DIFFERENT
HOUSE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, MY KIDS ARE
ATHLETES.
A WIN IS A WIN.
SOMETIMES YOU